I want to get you back to the point
where you ever fall because we have met
these for quite some time
however solitary experience
like this is just like algebra in
general is kind of your bread and butter
you're gonna be doing these left right
and center where we're introduced to
calculus okay so you really have to be
able to do this without thinking quickly
and accurately okay so that's why we're
focusing on it again we've learnt two
different methods for solving
simultaneous equations like there's two
different ways breaking down these two
equations into one and then solving one
of the two ways heads up substitution
someone else would have tell me
thank you Reina what's the other method
elimination just because they're
brothers it doesn't anyway I can't
refocus people if every time if every
time the twins walked in separately we
stop and discuss it we are gonna have a
very very long year okay two years okay
head back into space two methods we need
to know that well and we also need to be
able to determine when you should use
one and when you should use the other
and when it will be quicker for you of
course you can always take either party
right
you'll always be fine but depending on
the question you get one method will
almost certainly be quicker and less
error-prone for you so have a look at
what Inge with me what do you think
substitution or elimination sub seizure
I had it a few times good now why is
substitution a better choice
nice elimination will work fine here but
why is substitution a better choice for
this one be too good okay so it's all
about this is a speed theme right have
you ever had a big Xander you've gone
through it you felt like man that was a
long exam it may have been a long exam
but equally likely is that it wasn't a
lot easier you just picked the slow way
from variety questions brought it down
and that's what was the problem so
correct in equation one and that should
be the very first thing that you should
you should label your equations in
equation one you already have Y sitting
there on its own very easy to isolate
okay so let's set this out right I'm now
going to work with equation one I'm not
gonna bring it together with any other
equations on it it just sucks say
something this into that or this divided
by that or this minus that I'm just
going to say equation one never gonna
rearrange it okay y equals there you go
and now I'm already ready to substitute
right since I am taking an action that
relates these two equations together you
almost but you always mistake what
you're actually doing so that's not just
a string of equations where you like why
does this appear what does this have to
do with ATP okay so I think this is um
one of the few times when an irradiation
is pretty okay because completely
unambiguous what you are doing you don't
need to write the whole word substitute
say sub this into - okay they draw this
right now when I say we're trying to
develop speed and accuracy here these
are the kinds of things I'm focusing on
right as borne against the outside start
to appear in the exercise you need to
really be careful that you don't miss
any of them when you're expanding
because that's the easiest error to make
without sort of you know some people
have asked me yesterday we know how to
look at some of their equations hmm
where's the arrow
what am I done wrong why is my error my
it's a server Tico's and almost
certainly if you go
by mine you'll find a negative is always
always the culprit okay so let's go
ahead and expand 7x minus 16x will leave
us with - died X 53 minus 80 27 or 27th
and of course you just divide through
okay my god no of course I've not done
this is simultaneous equations right the
reason I'm given two equations is
because I have two variables right and
of course you can expand this if I were
given three variables I need three
equations four variables
four equations and so on okay so I'm
gonna have to substitute this back here
where would you like me to do it back
into and of course for the same reason
that substitution was a good choice
because Y is already just sitting there
okay so I'll say sub X okay a bit off I
go 6 plus y said now I'm done
ok my personal preference is that at the
very end you should say because
sometimes you just have to and sometimes
to get from the first solution to the
second one takes a long time I
personally prefer that at the very end
you say is I just gather all of your
solutions together in one spot the next
best alternative is to take another
color and where your answers are within
your working you can add a circle or put
one of these kinds of marks just
whatever you need to to highlight look
I've got a whole bunch of working but
here the critical parts that you need to
see